hey francis are you progressive of
course can't you see i'm transitioning
good point so as a progressive how would
you feel if a single person controlled
all the information in the world and
decided what we're allowed to say and
think yes twitter is a private platform
that should censor people who don't
agree with me that does sound very
progressive what if i told you this
person has built 2 million electric cars
to fight climate change yes what if i
told you he's african-american yes
diversity is our strength well i have
good news for you elon musk wants to buy
twitter
five minutes later
of deals later well what have you
stopped censoring people i don't agree
with well twitter is a private platform
what you said it yourself twitter is a
private platform that can decide who to
censor yeah but i didn't [ __ ] mean it
that's just something we say to win but
he's a good guy he was even a vegetarian
for a while so was hitler well isn't it
great to have an african-american in
charge you know for diversity you call
this diversity a straight white man who
believes in free speech i know he gave
his kid a gender non-binary name but
unless he identifies as a trans racial
lesbian who agrees with everything i say
this isn't good enough but he openly
criticized donald trump over climate
change and he's donated to the democrats
i don't care he's worse than hitler he
said pronouns suck and criticize woke
people well uri even adolph never went
as far as making fun of pronouns so do
you have a progressive solution to the
twitter problem yes it should be owned
by someone who agrees with everything i
say and who is kind and respectful like
who blackrock morgan stanley and the
saudi royal family that's who owns it
now exactly progress is about keeping
things just the way i like it
this is elon musk hey guys
[Applause]
[Music]
you